my name's Dave one of the producers of
our Firearms expert react series and I
got the chance to sit down with a couple
of the developers of hunt Showdown to
chat about how they implemented feedback
from the expert himself Jonathan
Ferguson over the talk we covered
everything from their response to the
original video from March 2021 what they
changed and how they approached the
game's weapon design so without further
Ado here's my catch up with some of the
fine folks behind hunt Showdown what was
your reaction when you saw that first
um
expert reacts video pop up and you know
saw your game tied to a historian and um
an expert sort of breaking down your
work I have been I have been following
the the FX react series uh for a while
as a as a webinarist I am very
interested in like how other games
realize their their weapons and uh not
only like art but like sound like
realism stuff and of course seeing our
work being portrayed was very exciting
we really care about our the about the
our work and the the stuff we do and we
we are not historians of course we are
not experts we are just like video game
you know uh artists and animators and
designers so it's really it's really
awesome to have uh someone who is really
knowledgeable about this stuff really
analyze and and dissect our work for me
for animation wise uh first off I think
it's really cool it's really interesting
for someone to look at our animation
because normally people talk about a
game play about the visual elements the
environment and stuff so it's really
cool to have someone with such a vast
knowledge of weapons to look at our
stuff
[Applause]
of all the games we've shown him I I
want to say like Hunt is probably like
the top 10 of things that he's enjoyed
watching and credited for its realism
and authenticity even when it's in like
a fantasy setting so is it I suppose
seeing critiques like that that are so
granular is it like both a source of
Pride and sometimes like anxiety that
there are things that are being picked
apart to such a degree yeah it's uh some
some of the things are of course like
our mistake because as I said we are not
the experts right and some of these
weapons of course we live in at least I
live in Europe it's not that easy to get
your hands on any of this like if we
were a U.S Studio it would be related to
just like go to whatever pawn shop get
like a bit early or something and and
then play with it right but we don't
really have the chance to to get
especially this really rare historical
weapons sometimes we we make a mistake
because we really don't know how it
actually worked sometimes it happens
that the limitations of a video game can
and the constrain us and we we cannot do
it perfectly realistic because of
whatever it could be animation
constraints could be maybe it's too
expensive or too many parts or something
for it for it to run we try very hard to
mimic real life sometimes we animate
stuff we try to make it as close to how
it should move in the real world like
timing wise how slow it should be how
heavy it should be but sometimes because
of the constraints and um there are so
many different weapons in game that we
have to balance them obviously like you
said you're in Europe and Singapore you
don't have access to a lot of these
weapons so what resources do you use
when when it comes to you know creating
virtual representations these weapons
like uh before
um we create uh something new a new
weapon for example
um weapon art for example Alex uh he
will source for all the blueprints that
he can find the references and he will
show us
how the gun mechanisms work and what are
the things to take note of and stuff is
very essential for us to look at
whatever blueprints or references that
we can find because Hunt is very
realistic we want to make it as
authentic as possible from the from the
art side I would say definitely yeah
blueprint or a lifesaver if we can get
our hands on them because with those we
make sure that the the proportions of
the weapon are correct not only because
like pictures can be maybe a little bit
distorted or skewed or something
depending on how how rare the weapon is
there might not even be a lot of
material online to to find information
about it right not blueprints or manuals
or something so sometimes you have to
kind of figure it out by yourself a
really high definition pictures are also
great that those allow us to basically
go really deep and put all the markings
and all the the text and all the little
like stamps and details on the weapons
like to really nail them and another
another great resource or video so
there's like some historical
um YouTube channels that help us a lot
that they they take these 19th century
weapons and like really analyze them
their history their design their their
patterns different patterns uh
throughout the their their lifetime and
uh yeah basically seeing seeing it in
movement seeing the the people handle it
like how it you know opening it
reloading it gives a real sense of you
know how difficult it is to to operate
yeah we need to get a lot of references
um since yeah we we of course cannot get
them so
the sparks llr in particular I believe
you were the first
um Studio at least publicly to come out
and say hey like this note was made in a
video from from Gamespot and we've
changed it what what made you want to
want to do that like there's there's
other weapons that were critiqued but
with the with the sparks in particular
what made you sort of take note look at
you know what was said and go back and
be like yeah we are going to change this
reload so for this box that hammer the
extra action on the hammer is we have
seen it is really a extra action and
because we want to uh animate as
realistically as possible so the
Redundant action should be taken out I
think we did not change the actual
reload time even if it doesn't do the
extraction with the hammer the reload
time stays the same and this this is for
balancing reasons because if we did it
more realistic then of course the reload
will be order and it would make the
Sparks more powerful in relation to
other guns and yeah so sometimes we make
reloading times uh longer or shorter for
for balancing the weapon and as we said
before we have so many weapons at this
point that we need to really take this
more variable uh constraints or more
variable things like the reload time
like maybe the damage or something as as
everything as we can to balance the
weapon in a but it still it feels
realistic so it was the sort of like a
meeting or you know a slack conversation
being like hey this has been pointed out
it's probably something that we can do
how how did how did that go down I'm not
sure exactly who pointed it out because
again we're really passionate about your
your Express react Series so a lot of a
lot of people in the team uh watch it
and uh and yeah I I guess it must have
been in animation because it wasn't
because of course that doesn't bend on
the art so it wasn't on us but some
somebody pointed it out in in the chat
and they were like well yeah let's
change it you know this is wrong and we
got this valuable bit of feedback so
let's apply it
thank you
your studio is very tied to your
community and engage with the community
a lot was there you know when you when
you posted that patch saying hey we've
updated the Sparks and this is why were
there was there like any interesting
responses from the community was it like
like hey cool like you took took that on
board or other people absolutely that
wasn't necessary yeah what was the what
was the response yeah the community was
really excited uh because uh the people
who are passionate about hand they're
usually also passionate about these
historical weapons and the realism and
seeing that we are that we are also
those people we are also part of the the
community that is uh very interested in
history very interested in in this like
all firearms and and they were really
excited that we actually listened and
that we took took notice and uh and did
the changes they were really excited it
was really nice to see it brings kind of
the the development team and the
community together in a way right
because we are basically fans of the
same things we we are we are them
basically like I was a member of the
community way way before I joined the
dev team off the back of of you know
either the the video itself or just for
the research and reading into things
have there been any other weapons that
you've sort of gone back and taken a
second look at and been like we could we
could tweak this tie it into reality and
it's real world counterparts a little
more yes there there was one one more
thing Jonathan noticed in the first
video that the some of our revolvers
like the the conversion and the packs do
not use the ejector rods to to reload
instead they do like some kind of
rubbing and then the the weapon uh
cartridges come out this is for a reason
but it's a somewhat kind of uh technical
obscure one basically our weapons are
modular which means that they are
comprised of of different parts right so
it's usually the the barrel the receiver
and the stock and normally to to kind of
make it easier on the on the animation
team and the technical art team only the
the receiver is animated so basically
only the the drum and the the trigger
the hammer basically the things that
usually move when the weapon Cycles uh
only that part is animated the problem
with those revolvers is that the the
ejector Rod is in the barrel so we
either make like a kind of really big
receiver with like a lot of parts and
stuff or we still need to split it
because we need to make for example
longer pistol versions or like local
socks or whatever so in this case it was
decided this was before my time but it
was decided that the uh the ejector rod
parts should remain static they just
tweak the animations and then yeah
that's it we we had a look at it at how
complex it would be to to actually fix
it and actually kind of convert all of
our revolvers to to use this this new
piece to use the the ejector the problem
is that we have so many weapons and so
many legendary weapons that some of them
for example are like carbine versions
right and they maybe don't have an
ejector or maybe in some legendary skins
the ejector is broken so we of course we
we couldn't use it because it's
literally not there so we would have to
make bespoke uh animations and in
bespoke rigs for all of these uh
legendaries which are again a lot
because the game is at this point like
four years old so we decided that the
the payoff which is like making the guns
slightly more realistic wasn't really
worth the amount of the amount of hours
that we would have to put in so we did
look at it but unfortunately the result
is that it Remains the Same
thanks again to Winnie and Alex for
their insight into the art and animation
process behind the scenes of hunt
Showdown if you want to see Jonathan's
take on Han Showdown make sure to check
out both the episodes we've done on the
game thanks for watching and I'll catch
you next time
[Music]